be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with Suicide Squad being released in
theaters this week what I wanted to do
here is take a look at the many weapons
and gadgets that the Joker is employed
over his long history and comics
film and television and what I'm hoping
is that by the end of this video you'll
come away with a better understanding of
the Joker's arsenal in time for the
Suicide Squad film so due to the faculty
has no superhuman abilities The Joker
relies on a variety of weapons and
gadget ritu takedown as enemies and
while the Joker does use conventional
weapons such as guns and knives the main
focus of our discussion today is going
to be on the weapons that are unique to
him one of the Joker's most well known
and most often use weapons is the Joker
venom and first appeared in Batman issue
number one Joker venom is a toxin that
could exist in both gas or liquid form
and the effects of Joker venom vary from
story to story however in almost every
case those who were exposed to the venom
suffer from compulsive and
uncontrollable fits of laughter and see
their faces contorted into an
exaggerated smile in addition to this
Joker venom comes in both lethal and
non-lethal forms and has been
administered through a variety of
delivery systems such as being shot from
a gas gun in its first appearance to
being stored in the Joker's lapel flower
and even being poured in Gotham's water
system in Detective Comics number 475
resulting in the creation of Joker fish
which bore the Joker's signature gren
now the story of The Joker Venom's
creation has multiple versions Detective
Comics number 168 an Alan Moore's
killing Joe graphic novel credit the
Joker himself with the Venom's creation
due to his past as a chemical plant
worker while in Batman legends The Dark
Knight number 50 the credit goes to the
Joker's autistic cousin Melvin a
chemistry sivan that the Joker tricks
into creating the compound in addition
to its mini comic book appearances the
Joker venom also appears in the 1989 Tim
Burton film as Smile X a chemical of the
Joker's creation administered through
various hygiene products and gas filled
balloons as well as in Batman the
Animated Series and the Arkham Knight
video game now a different version of
the Joker venom was seen in the 2001 a
miniseries Joker's last laugh by Chuck
Dixon and Robert Beatty instead of
killing those who came into contact with
it it transformed them into fact
siblings of the Joker complete with
white skin green hair and permanent
exaggerated grins in addition to
physical transformation those who came
in
contact with the venom were completely
subservient and obedient to the Joker
and in Batman number 663 let her Grant
Morrison revealed that the Joker's
consumption of the Joker venom over the
years had made him immune to its effects
also making their debut in Batman number
one were various other weapons including
a pair of exploding chattering teeth and
playing cards with razor-sharp edges
that can be thrown similarly to Batman's
batarangs and Joker's lapel flower which
has at various times squirted Joker
venom laughing gas poison or water
another of Joker's most frequent used
weapons is his electric joy-buzzer a
device Joker conceals in the palm of his
hand so that he can administer an
electric shock to anyone he shakes hands
with this device made its appearance in
Batman number 73 in 1952 in a story
called Joker's utility belt in Tim to
rival that of Batman's also included in
the utility belt were items such as
exploding cigarettes sneezing powder
hitching powder snake pellets playing
cards Mexican jumping beans and several
other seemingly innocuous prank Gatos
I'm sorry guys I had to laugh although
something I really want to see Batman
having Mexican jumping beans thrown at
him if this needs to happen in a movie
although sometimes using the joy buzzer
to simply incapacitated victims Joker
most often uses it as a means of murder
holding on to his victims hand long
enough for the electrical current to
stop their heart a version of the buzzer
also appears in the 1989 Batman film
which leaves Joker's victim a charred
smoldering corpse another common weapon
of the Joker's is a harpoon flag gun
bearing the appearance of a regular
pistol when the triggers pulled the gun
discharges a flag with the word bang or
pal printed on it giving those at whom
the gun is fired at the impression that
the gun is simply a practical joke when
the triggers pulled a second time
however the gun fires a flag itself from
the barrel which impales a victim like a
harpoon now from time to time the Joker
is depicted wielding a cane in 1991 we
learn that another one of the Joker's
weapons is a sword concealed within his
cane that he uses to battle Tim Drake
and Chuck Dixon's Robin to Joker's wild
miniseries another of Joker's weapons
comes in the form of a boxing glove
attached to an extendable arm that he
uses to punch enemies this weapon is
sometimes attached
to a gun and activates when the triggers
pulled the joker uses this weapon in the
1989 Batman movie as well as a 2004
animated series the Batman The Joker's
also expanded his repertoire to include
various vehicles before example in
Batman number 37 in 1946 the Joker makes
another attempt to imitate Batman by
creating the Joker gyro to mimic
Batman's bat plane and the Joker mobile
his version of the Batmobile which was
bulletproof as well as being armed with
machine guns that also had the ability
to lay down planks that allow the car to
pass over open spaces and both of these
vehicles prominently feature the Joker's
face on the front of them however this
would be the only appearance of the
Joker gyro that I could find
but the Joker mobile would appear
several more times throughout the years
although it would be redesigned twice
now the Joker's gadgetry has also been
heavily featured in its various
videogame depictions Joker's character
and Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe
includes his various extendable boxing
glove arm and razor sharp playing cards
along with a bomb and a revolver
likewise during injustice gods among us
the Joker
incorporates his acid shooting lapel
flower laughing gas exploding chattering
teeth and a crowbar a nod to the weapon
the Joker used to maim the second Robin
Jason Todd in the death of the family
story art by jim Starlin in 1988 and
1989 furthermore the Arkham series of
games adds x-ray glasses to the Joker's
array of gadgets as well as including
the Joker teeth and Joker venom although
it is referred to variously as smile Lex
Joker toxin or happy gasp that said in
recent years the Joker has been depicted
as a darker and more deranged character
and as such has resorted to using more
conventional and violent weapons instead
of those based around jokes and pranks
for instance the Joker's
characterization in the 2008 film The
Dark Knight sees the Joker as he's
portrayed by Heath Ledger depicted as a
murderous psychopath that uses
conventional weapons such as grenades
and bombs as well as conventional items
like pencils and razor blades to inflict
harm and even kill his victims whether
the version of the Joker portrayed by
Jared Leto in Suicide Squad will
incorporate any of these traditional
gadgets into his character remains to be
seen although trailers indicate that
this version of the Joker will exhibit
at least some of the sadistic tendencies
that have become a hallmark of his more
recent characterization well that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and what I want to do here is I
want to pose a question to you guys if
you guys could defeat Batman using any
one of the
hookers gadgets which gadget would it be
and I will catch you guys later please